first of all congrats on your movie
i really enjoyed it and um i have a lot
of questions about it
but i want to know specifically with you
it's really hard in hollywood
to just direct or to make it as an actor
to make it as a producer and one of the
things i think people don't realize
about you is
you've been an actor a director a
producer
you've won an oscar for producing you've
been on the stage
you are very hard to pin down as one
like just one thing
how the f did you pull this off
well thank you i don't know if i pulled
it off quite yet
but i'm still pretending to no uh
i got really lucky early on as an
actor i started working quite a bit in
my uh
late teens and early 20s um
mostly stage and actually only stage and
film but
then um i got a little curious about
doing other things and
i uh i wanted a little more control and
i wanted to choose who i was going to
work with so i formed a theater company
when i was i co-founded this theater
company called naked angels
in the 80s and naked angels was a place
where
a bunch of us as actors new york theater
actors
gave each other the space to write
direct produce
plays and i got the bug and i we started
like making this making theater together
and that then gave me the confidence to
start trying to make movies as a
producer and a director
and i just i mean that took a lot more
time that was a very
uh not a very satisfying financial
endeavor
um my bread and butter was definitely
acting
for many years until i um
you know started to focus a little bit
more on the producing directing
and then i just was able to balance it
and i discovered the world of
documentaries
because i was producing a lot of movies
and i
i produced a documentary about soccer in
america
when pele came to play for the new york
cosmos with
franz beckenbauer georgio canalia
carlos alberto and they kind of turned
american soccer upside down and tried to
bring it to america
and the film that i was producing was
terrible so the
my partner said you better fix this man
and then i just went to film school for
documentary filmmaking on that movie
fell in love with that medium and then
my life kind of took this other turn
so i just was lucky that i got to
discover docs and i'd say that's been a
big profound effect a huge profound
effect on my life since
but i like the balance i like the
balance of all of it
you've done a lot of theater work and
every time i talk to people that do
theater work i'm always curious if you
can talk about
the differences in audiences depending
on where you're performing for example
if you're off-broadway if you are
like do you notice that there's
different audiences and that
different energy depending on where you
are
oh huge audience is very uh
you know when i did my first big play
was uh a cult hit uh called torch song
trilogy
and um the audience was you know it's a
play it's
it it was kind of a groundbreaking play
written by harvey fierstein openly gay
about uh many it was three parts and
the last part was about a gay couple
that adopted a teenager me
um it was quite groundbreaking but the
audiences were you know
wild i mean wild uh
harvey had this cult following so and
then i went from that to neil
simon brighton beach memoirs on broadway
which also was
wild audiences but for all other reasons
um so i was spoiled those audiences
doing comedic work
getting those laughs it was the greatest
thing that ever happened
um and actually one thing some people
don't know
unless you do theater is that even your
audiences
on uh tuesday night and a wednesday
night are not nearly as good as an
audience
on a thursday night or a saturday night
uh or friday night you know it all
varies even the different nights you
have historic audiences
for the night saturday nights tend to be
like lousy audiences because they go out
to dinner beforehand the
people usually get full and they don't
laugh as much you know
but then you do like you know
off-broadway or when i would do naked
angels
the reason i sort of stopped doing plays
is i was starring in this play called
shyster
playing the lead character in this small
theater in midtown manhattan
and the audiences didn't not only gave
me nothing
i got slammed reviews were terrible
and i thought wow i'm busting my hump
for no money
i'm gonna break take a break from
theater as an actor
because those audiences did not respect
or appreciate my performance
at all uh speaking of documentaries
which was the one that really was a pain
in the ass to get financing for the one
that was just
a ball buster to get made i'd say
uh the you know i i gotta say this is
gonna sound really
uh i don't know no one probably says
this but
i've had not a lot of difficulty getting
documentaries financed
um uh the one where i went out on the
limb
the most financially was uh carrie
fisher debbie reynolds bright lights
um we my my girlfriend
uh basically like my wife and i co-made
that together but
we funded the beginning of that
ourselves and
uh we paid for it and shot for a while
and then we pitched it to hbo uh who
who then ended up uh financing it
but um i've done that a few times um
but for some reason nothing was as
difficult to get made as palmer
in terms of for me like that to me was
the most difficult
uh one of the most difficult things
to to get made that i've been involved
with and uh
yeah with that film you're tackling
subject matter
that not a lot of people like talk about
you know um and especially because of
the the the boy in the film
yeah yeah feature films
are difficult to get funding for uh when
i had my production company
my partner and i at the time we had this
big fight uh
bennett miller and philip hoffman came
to our office to pitch us capote
and uh you know i really wanted to make
it my partner
didn't and um it was a risk you know
phil
phil hadn't starred in a movie before
and uh
you know that movie had a lot of trouble
getting made and that was one of the
best movies i'd ever seen
you know um a lot of movies have trouble
getting made
and you know
the doc world is you know there have
been docs that i've wanted to make
that weren't financed that i just didn't
make um
but in terms of dots that i made pretty
much
i've been able to um find funding for
relatively easily compared to feature
films you know
um i don't know why it's a weird
it's just it's just the way the world
works well first of all docs are a lot
cheaper
um and and docs have social you know
there's a lot of social
impact in a lot of the docs that we make
so
people want to push social impact
agendas
so you can find money but the the palmer
palmer took you know there were a lot of
starts and stops that was a
that was really tough um
to make uh and and get up off the ground
and it was tough to make while we were
making it just because of the restraints
and the restrictions
yeah believe me i have about 72
questions on palmer and we're almost
there
but um i need to also talk about the
fact that you produce tiger king
um which is obviously you never know
when you sign up when you
decide to develop something what's going
to happen with it you hope for the best
when did you realize that you had
something special with tiger king
well that was a long journey as well
tiger king
started i mean eric good who's one of
the two directors
um was uh after i did the cove
he called me and he was a friend of mine
um and i knew
that he had uh this thing called the
turtle conservancy
and he asked me to look at footage that
he had filmed
in uh china and in indonesia about him
going into wet markets
um buying uh endangered species
that were available so he showed me that
he's like we should do a movie i'm like
i think this is a series
and we started talking about doing a
series about reptiles and
and rebecca uh shakeland who
we had just done a movie on occupy wall
street uh
and a movie on uh people making
decisions i just done two dots with her
uh i said you know rebecca and him had
teamed up
and it took a long time to figure out
what tiger king was because originally
it was more of a movie about or a series
about monkey
moms uh people that like owned exotic
pets
um but they hadn't discovered joe exotic
yet or the
story and then but we were made we were
trying to make something
and then when they discovered joe exotic
and carol baskin it was pretty clear
that that was
oh oh wait this is a whole other
situation so
uh they you know i was in and out of
that
i i started just i was i had to make a
living uh
because there wasn't any money there and
they started filming and getting it
together and then when they add more
stuff
i was like holy [ __ ] this is
incredible and uh and
and you know and then we brought it to
netflix and
started putting it together as as that
show
and we thought it was we thought it was
gonna be good
and and people would be into it but we
we didn't think obviously
there was going to be a global pandemic
and it was going to be the first thing
that everybody started to watch
timing is everything timing is
everything when you have that kind of
success
um and look i know that netflix must
have been like thank you so much
this is great because it's such a huge
hit what happens after that with like a
netflix do they all of a sudden call you
and say
so what's the next thing i wish
i think i think they don't i think
netflix
you know i've done well
the reason we had such access to netflix
was because i had done
a couple movies with them before and i
i brought uh this friend of mine on to
help
put the whole thing together at the end
chris smith who had just done the fire
dock
for them which was another huge hit so
we had a real good track record with
netflix
um but no i think netflix has so many
you know they're they don't care who
makes what i think they just want to
keep making good things and they don't
care who made them at this point they
could get whatever they want
you know uh but they're good people
and you know certainly they've been
great to me um i've done
that was my fourth tiger king was my
fourth uh
fourth documentary with them siri you
know not
i'd done three docs and then you know so
i
i was really lucky uh of course uh like
everyone i'm a huge fan of succession
and i just have to ask um when you got
involved in the project
did you what what pulled you in on that
was it the writing
like how did you get involved and you
know what i mean
yeah so i um
i watched a little of succession but um
this guy that i'd met uh
in brooklyn in the neighborhood was uh
a few years before he was going off to
do the pilot of succession as a producer
and we got to be friends we were trying
to do a united nations kind of tv show
we had a mutual friend at the u.n and i
remember him saying that and then
um i i don't know i think i bumped into
him or i got this message from him
that uh you know have i seen succession
there's a little part they wanted me to
play
um and i i had seen it and i was like
oh my god that's the show [ __ ] that show
is so good
holy [ __ ] um so
so they asked me to do a couple episodes
and
as soon as i got to the set i was
these are the coolest actors these are
the coolest people i just felt so
comfortable
and i just was hoping they'd just keep
asking me back and it just worked out
um because they are it's like
i i said this on a few interviews but it
is like having a
being part of a theater troupe and
you're part of an ensemble and it
reminded me of being in my theater
company
because everybody is so
cool and everybody's from the theater on
that show a lot of actors who've done
stage
and there's a lot of support for each
other and it's just a great environment
and i hadn't experienced that that much
doing tv where
it was like a family and it was like
well it was more like a theater company
it's how i could only way i could
describe it
and uh so yeah so then they asked me
back this year and i was like of course
anything i'll do it's a joy to be part
of this uh
amazing ensemble and these amazing
writer producers and
yeah it's it's great i think season
three is going to be just as good as the
others
yeah they have this thing called good
writing um
and uh you know i've noticed that it's
it you know it's kind of good
um have you noticed though because
you've done so many things in your
career
have you you can tell when something is
really popular i'm sure by what happens
when you go to the supermarket
you know or when you're out in public
when people always want to talk to you
about something
obviously now because everyone's wearing
a mask i think you're a little more
anonymous
but did you notice before the pandemic
that people were like
constantly wanting to talk about
succession or was it something else
uh yeah you know your succession is
definitely it's funny i did um
succession is a
great thing because it's the i'm finally
on a show that all my friends watch
right you know um so they see you
uh and that's exciting i've done a lot
of stuff that my friends
are like where you been what are you
doing and i'm like well i'm doing this
they're like
what is that i'm like oh okay so
um yeah
but yeah people love to talk about
succession um no matter where you are um
you know i'm i'm i'm working on a
documentary now about the lincoln
project
um the people you know the lincoln
project so very aware
so so those guys all watch succession
so it's very interesting to uh
you know that those guys all you know
it's like you guys want success
cool okay it is something that people
love to talk about
for sure um succession and uh
they're always like when is it coming
back when is it coming back
it's good to be it's good people are
looking forward to something
uh that's my last question on it um i
have to ask where are you
in the filming process have you guys
started filming are you
what where are you at uh yeah we're in
we're we've been filming for about two
months okay so
you're pretty far along
yeah it takes a long time in these
worlds you know
you wear a mask and a shield you know
then they call you to the set and do the
scene take it off and then they
you know uh things take a little longer
in cobin you know but yeah
got it you're on episode you're two
months you're on episode three i get it
yeah ish
um okay well i have some other stuff but
i want to jump into why i get to talk to
you in case your headphones
uh go dead with palmer you talked about
how it was a challenge
to actually make the film can you sort
of talk about because some projects
take you know all of a sudden you have a
script and you're in front of cameras
like within a year and other projects
could take a decade uh talk a little bit
about when you got involved in the
project
and maybe what pulled you into it that
said i want to spend time making this
i read the script in 2016 it wasn't uh
like oh
here do you want to direct this it was
more like my agent going do you like
this type of material
i said i like this material i want to
direct this
and he said i think there's a director
and i said well just in case they fall
apart let me meet with
the people that own it and the writer
so i met with them they uh that
i guess there was a director the
director did fall out
they called me and said okay but
meanwhile a director falling out
it still wasn't like a studio movie that
was green lit it still had to get
financing and
casting so you know these are
independent films how do you make an
independent film you need a star
to star in it uh to get the financing
approved blah blah blah as you know
you probably interviewed many many
people have told you that
story and you know it yourself but so it
was like a game of a list of six
actors get one of the six and
you can get financing and in 2018
um i worked on the script quite a bit
with cheryl the writer who's fabulous
uh i had a possible actor that was on
the list saying that he may do it i
started casting the boy
because the boy is the big you know sam
you need sam
uh and i i started scouting locations it
looked all like it was happening
and the money kind of fell apart and the
actor's schedule started shifting and
that was it i lost and it was like oh my
god
i was so depressed man i was so
depressed i turned down even a
netflix acting role on a series money
blah blah blah
so anyway um i was trying to figure this
out and i
i was making this other documentary with
decap leonardo dicaprio and
i gave the script to his agent like who
would you play as
palmer and they said to his manager
sorry
and they said uh this is perfect for
justin
and i'm like justin justin thoreau he's
too
he's too old for this justin timberlake
i went
wow that's interesting
justin timberlake yeah he's from the
south
he's like whoa he's a great actor i
didn't think of that
so then it became a long
courting process you know he's a big
star he's on tour
for his concert he hadn't acted in a
while he's been making music
and uh i i uh
you know because i i just had to make
this film like nothing was gonna stop me
i love this character of sam he was like
my nephew max
i love this character of palmer he was a
guy going back to try to get second
chances
i love stories of redemption i love that
it was set in the south in red state
america
i love the fact that that i could
go inside of this world go inside of
these people's heads
i thought i knew so much i didn't know
[ __ ] you know like i needed to learn
more about this country that i lived and
i raised in i wanted to learn
about other people in the country what
was going on and i wanted to
tell a story of hope and the story of
people who come together
and i just said this is the story and i
also wanted to find a script that i
could bring
what i've been doing on in the dark
world to
fiction you know like be able to kind of
take all these years of making docs and
and put it into my fictional work um
use it telling a a a fictional story in
a very authentic real life way
so i basically told justin what i just
told you and i think he
kind of got that and kind of felt like
that's
yeah and he loved the story and you know
it took a long time as i said and then
he said like look man
i'll make this but we're not going to
start shooting till we have this kid
so i said i know i have the kid i think
he may still be able to do it so i
called that kid that i was gonna cast
and i read him again and he had grown
he was too old his voice was so we had
to start over
and justin is like look man i need
i'll give you two days of just reading
kids if you need to so find
find me six kids and i thought i had the
kid
i thought i had one or two really good
choices but i couldn't find
six and at the last minute this kid
ryder allen's tape that i
i auditioned him i thought he was good
but he was seven
he was so young and i was trying to cast
somebody a little older so i had more
time to shoot with
and somebody who may have a little bit
more maturity
and there was just once justin and ryder
got into the room together there was no
denying that this guy ryder was sam
and that these two together were going
to be
sam and palmer it just felt right and it
and thank god
it was right yeah i was going to say
that um this whole movie
uh uh falls on rider's shoulders if
if you don't believe in the kid and you
don't believe in the relationship with
justin
um the movie's game over um but ryder is
so good in the role
um uh i guess what what was it
that because you never know with like uh
what that spark is do you remember
was it just an overall once you started
reading with justin you're like oh this
this is it
there was this weird thing you know and
as an actor i'm
always aware like one thing i do and and
when i direct
actors is i say listen people you need
to listen
there was something about the two of
them they listen to each other
and listening is so key to acting and
great acting
and they listened to each other and
responded and reacted
in a natural way that i didn't see
any of the other kids doing with justin
and
i also thought justin was kind of in the
auditions he was carrying a lot of these
kids
on his shoulders you know he was pushing
them you
with ryder it it wasn't like that uh
ryder
held his own against justin and
that was what it was ryder is not what i
envisioned sam to be like to look like
um at all but it didn't matter
it was he was sam and my
vision of sam originally wasn't
necessarily the right vision of sam and
i
let go of it instantly once ryder came
into the picture
uh with justin i would imagine that he
is offered other scripts and he's you
know being
given opportunities because of who he is
and the star power that he brings
um talk a little bit about when what
when and where was it that justin
finally said to you
i want to do this movie like let's make
this movie and sort of your reaction
because you know landing him means you
might get financing
or you can do financing exactly exactly
well i've told this story before but um
you know i was in scotland um
shooting a scene uh i had a very tiny
tiny part in the scene but we were
shooting succession
and it was when jeremy strong's
character kendall
is uh doing a rap song for his dad
uh in one of the episodes and
uh because of the time difference uh we
were shooting nights it was like 2 a.m
in scotland um i i had been like
waiting for justin and freaking out
um like i don't i i mean you know i'm
like
i'm getting like my you know
so impatient and frustrated will he do
it won't he do it
and i remember at uh we were on a break
right before
you know jeremy did the rap song and i
called his manager rick yorn and i'm
like rick
what is going on man i gotta know and he
said dude
it's gonna happen it's gonna work out
relax
trust me it's all gonna be okay
and i i said really rick because rick
you know he's a manager but he's he's
straight up
and he said yeah man and then i said
just
have him text me to and then sure enough
justin says yo bro let's chat in the
morning but i'm really excited about
this
and i was like yes and that was it was
in scotland and then i felt like he's
gonna
do this thing man he's gonna do this
thing and uh
then jeremy did the rap song and i just
was really shouting
but i was thinking about how great
justin is gonna do the movie but i'm
pretending that jeremy's like
justin up there screaming so it was a
great moment
i know exactly the scene you're talking
about and that's a great behind the
scenes
of that scene yeah you know one of the
reasons why i really responded to the
movie
is that it just the movie is like a
really beautiful
message about understanding and you know
um
and not everyone is the same and you
know
everyone should be treated with respect
and um
can you sort of talk about like the
underlying message of the film
and you know it's a really beautiful
message the message of the film is
is acceptance and and it's
forgiveness and its redemption
i think um the redemption part being the
the palmer part
um and the acceptance part being both
palmer
and sam being accepted in
in the world for who they are i mean it
was very tough for palmer to come back
to his small hometown
after committing a horrible crime and
after being the town's great
kind of great hope and then
disappointing the town by committing
this terrible crime
and then trying to get back into society
not easy you know um and he's feeling
very low about himself and i don't think
i think palmer and justin and i don't we
talked about this a little bit but like
he's first really excited about coming
back home
but then when he gets back home and he
sees the people staring at him and he
feels the eyes on him i think it's like
[ __ ] you know this is gonna be a tough
journey
and often people go back in
and they start to self-destruct again
start to go back to their old habits
what if they had them
and i think that sam gives palmer
this reason to
like himself again to like palmer
himself
and gives palmer this meaning
of of being alive a meaning of
moving forward and and
and and and you know sam
has his terrible situation at home with
his mother she's
addicted to meth she abandons him for
weeks at a time
just leaves him with vivian yet the one
thing his mother gave him was
the confidence to be who he is
the confidence to just say i love you
sam you know you can wear a barrette
you can play with dolls you can play
dress up
i don't give a [ __ ] i love you just the
way you are so she gives him this
beautiful
this kind of self-confidence and his
strength and
uh it's really interesting um
that this woman who was so tortured and
such a bad mother on the one hand
actually had this other parenting skill
on the other hand and um yeah and then
just to see a man like palmer kind of
open
and that was kind of you know what
justin and i also worked on it's just
this slow burn of falling for this kid
and starting to appreciate and starting
to let him seep into your pores
um so i i just feel like these movies
are important
and these characters are important to
give a voice and
uh that's i guess why i just felt so
destined to have to make this film is it
a little nice
to not have to worry about the opening
weekend box office
yeah it's funny you say that um
yeah it's a different world right like
my last movie
uh i did which was a very different
situation
with stand-up guys and i didn't have
like it wasn't
this was like my it's this is all on my
back it's like
all on me i hired the crew i hired the
cast i my producers gave me a lot of
room to
make the film i wanted to make the other
one was more of a gun
i was a hired you know gun and the
producer was financing the movie and
you know wouldn't let me necessarily
hire my dp my
designer you know what i mean it was a
different story so
when that movie opened in bomb at the
box office
you know nobody saw it and by the way i
wasn't so happy with the rollout
i mean i guess they had confidence in it
because they put it in all these
theaters but
um it was it was devastating
uh to me and then they basically pulled
it after the first weekend it was
it was it was really rough um so
yeah this is a whole other situation um
we're in 30 theaters 25 theaters but it
doesn't matter we know those theaters
are going to only have 25
capacity because of covid and we know
that like
it's a different world order and the
reason
that um you know i only had a few
options
to sell the movie to because i i didn't
know where it was going and come
june and july we knew the theaters
weren't going to be opening
so we had to sell it to a streamer and i
i know there was something about apple
that just felt so right for this movie
and i'm just so grateful that they are
taking a chance on us
and they're they're getting it out there
it's gonna get out there yeah the thing
about apple which i um which is good for
you
is that they're very selective with what
they put on the platform
they are um there's not an over
abundance of product
so they have limited movies limited
series and if
you know and it's easier to shine a
light on something
because they're so selective while i
love netflix they put everything on
netflix
well yeah yeah that's that's the
thinking matt
and the two people that run the film
division have been incredibly supportive
and i feel like i'm working at a real
with real filmmakers you know
uh so uh i mean matt used to work
you know run work at south by southwest
so he you know
it's it's got that real it's got a cool
feeling
and uh yeah we're really excited so yeah
thank god i don't have to worry about
the box office but
then reviews become super important you
know
obviously so that's an i'm very worried
you know you get very nervous about that
and because reviews kind of take on a
new life
there's more outlets more people writing
about more things and
you know it's it's just scary what what
one person will read and
what one person another person reads so
yeah i'm curious uh i wanted to jump in
real quick about talking about editing
and uh did you have like a much longer
cut of the movie or was it pretty much
what you released is pretty close to
what you had in the edit
much longer cut uh yeah i much longer
cut
um and you know my editor uh
jeff he uh he did the cove with me he
did before the flood with me
um we do a lot of he did racing
extinction with me we've done a lot of
docks together
and uh we've had a great relationship
over the years so
uh we we knew each other really well um
but there was a lot more that we shot
that ended up uh not in the movie
because
like a documentary i kept the camera
rolling quite a bit
um and uh yeah there were longer cuts
but we felt this was the this is the
right
leg the right you know we we really pain
we're paying
paying strict attention to every single
frame
uh of this film uh it was weird i have
to say not editing
not not screening very much for an
audience and being
getting the feel of the people in the
room because of kovid
um that was a real drag i really missed
that um
i certainly sent the film to a number of
friends to watch and give me notes but
i have to say i really missed that
experience of
showing it in a room full of people and
getting that vibe i got to do it a
couple times
before covid which were really helpful
but they were earlier cuts
obviously so um i i did really really
miss that
yeah there's nothing i don't think
people realize what it's like
because um you know people don't realize
that you've watched the movie a thousand
times
you know every frame so it's no longer
i've spoken to directors who talk about
cutting out funny parts of the movie
because it's not funny to them anymore
and they need to be reminded oh yeah
this works yes
yeah well i didn't do that thank god
let me ask you this though so i forget
how long the movie is it's
two hours and five or ten minutes
i think maybe no no it's less
an hour oh it's an hour 50 something
yeah yeah
did you i got it confused with something
else so did you have like a two and a
half hour director's cut
or two a two hour 45 minute director's
cut or was it only like a little bit
you know no i think you know
um i had a two hour and thirty minute
cut for sure
uh that we screened early on to see what
we had to lose
um but that quickly became two hours and
10 minutes and that quickly became
our you know hour 59
no i i'm really there's nothing in this
that i was like
uh i wish i didn't cut it um
no i mean like there's a couple things i
wish i
directed better moments uh but
a lot of it was due to the fact that
there just was no time
you know um i'm not gonna tell you what
but there's a location that i
i i just didn't have enough time you
know and so i had to just
you know there's a couple of moments in
the movie where i'm like oh if i only
had another
hour two hours or you know i know i'm
just i've already
pushed you beyond but i have to ask you
i know who the lincoln project is
what made you want to make a dock about
them if you don't mind me asking
um i was making a bunch of trying to
make a bunch of
uh psas uh to say
trump wake up people are dying of covet
what is your [ __ ] problem like do
something
and uh just not for profit just helping
people out
and then i saw a morning in america that
they did and i was like holy [ __ ] we'll
what are we even doing look let's just
play this
and then every time i get mad i would
just start watching these ads and they
were all so great
and then i realized they were made by
people that like i've been fighting my
whole political life against
um you know i've been very politically
active and you know i
fought against the iraq war i protested
against you know
uh i mean i could go on and on um
what these people who they've worked
with
but they i i had an opportunity uh i met
uh george conway on a zoom call
and then he said to a friend of mine
that their uh the linky project is
interested in
is people are going to them to make
documentary and my friend goes well
fischer should do that
and i said uh yeah and then
um we raised some money and and i
you know but there were a lot of people
trying to make documentary about them
and then we had
basically they have nothing to do with
the documentary other than they're
giving
me access my team so they interviewed a
bunch of us
and they chose me and my friend kareem
to do it
um and so we've been we were embedded
with them
during the campaign they they set up a
place
and uh yeah i shot i did a zoom
interview this
uh this morning for three hours you
don't mind me asking how long have you
been filming
we started filming september 1st looking
at the calendar and you've been filming
until now
yeah i can't imagine the amount of
footage you have
a lot a lot a lot there are a lot of
people in the league project
uh is there a pla in your mind do you
want to try to get it done for like say
this year's toronto film festival
there's no plan what it is yet we
haven't even sold it we've just been
funded by individuals we haven't even
really uh
yeah we haven't even started that part
process we i just want to know what the
film is so now
we're finally kind of understand what
we're doing so
it's been a it's been a long i mean with
the insurgency at the
capitol on january 6th it kind of added
a whole other color to the film
obviously and um yeah and the lincoln
project is really focusing on crews and
holly and the enablers right now
so if you look at their new ads that's
basically what they're
attacking my last thing so you're
working on that doc
and you're obviously filming succession
are you are you currently working on
other things or is the lincoln project
the thing that's really
driving your time right now no
succession is very much driving my time
as well
so it's those it's those three things
yeah i'm producing um a documentary
uh i just started i'm i'm just producing
it um
it it's dealing uh with uh the zulu
social aid and pleasure club in
louisiana and new orleans it's an
interesting doc
um that uh i i learned about them when i
was filming palmer in new orleans uh you
know i was staying in new orleans for
part of
the time i was filming palmer and i
learned about this
great amazing uh a kind of
you know social club called the zulu
social aid and pleasure club
so i uh i'm i'm i'm kind of shepherding
i'm not directing
great group of people working with me on
that so that's my other
project that i don't have to direct so
it's not as much time consuming as
as lincoln project or the um
uh succession obviously and i want to
get you know on getting this film out as
my priority
palmer and you know finding another
fiction piece to direct hopefully
soon uh with justin hopefully again
would be fun
same cast i loved i loved everybody we
just had such a great time
yeah uh you know what's interesting what
i really also um
my last question on palmer so one of the
things about the palmer's character is
he actually doesn't talk a lot
was that always scripted or was that
something that you worked on
on set justin's like do i need to say
this line
that was the script that was the script
that was
cheryl's homage to like a few of like
these great
you know early paul newman you know cool
and luke or
hud and steve mcqueen and you know those
kind of silent but brooding guys that
you know and then when they do talk like
when he confesses to alicia about what
he did
you know they they can't stop you know
talking with his fists
at times you know which is what
unfortunately some men
choose to do uh
that was a very conscious decision